katia où en est le cortège et commence
parce que la manifestation au lendemain
de heurts entre pompiers et forces de
l'ordre
oui il ya une toute autre ambiance ici
en ce moment cette manifestation qui se
dirige tranquillement vers les invalides
une bonne ambiance pas deux heures j'ai
entendu les sifflets derrière moi mais
franchement c'est le seul là ce n'est
pas le seul petit incident et encore ce
n'est même pas un je rappelle que ce
cortège s'est réunie à l'initiative de
la cgt de la de fo fsu et solidaires ya
aussi des personnes de sud
tous contestent ce projet de loi son
projet de réforme des retraites
évidemment ils n'ont pas baissé la garde
contrairement à certains autres
syndicats qui se sont rangés à l'avis de
cette réforme
et puis il ya aussi les organisations de
jeunes ce qui donne énormément de monde
des milliers de personnes c'est
difficile de nous a donné un chiffre n'a
pas eu de ficelle pour le moment mais je
vais vous dire que la mobilisation est
intacte sur le terrain mobiliser contre
ce projet de réforme alors parlons-en
puisque les deux projets de loi
organique et ordinaire ont été déposées
à l'assemblée nationale et les
discussions dans l'hémicycle démarreront
à partir du 17 février
la détermination du gouvernement elle
est intacte 1 pour faire passer cette
réforme
mais les oppositions ne manquent pas
dans la rue là l'occasion des citoyens
mais également l'opposition du conseil
d'état d'une certaine manière qui a eu
des critiques très vives envers le
projet est il
expliqué que le projet de loi avait des
projections financières lacunaire et
qu'il était peu lisible et puis du côté
de l'opposition aussi les députés de la
gauche c'est un communiste
insoumis et socialiste s'apprête à
déposer une motion de censure
fin février donc tout le monde est là
pour essayer de bloquer cette réforme
est justement en parlant des insoumis
nous étions tout à l'heure près de
l'heure ce temps nous avons recueilli
les propos de jean-luc mélenchon a le
leader de la france en tunisie de
bastien lachaud député a soumis je vous
propose les écouter le rap se dégrade
sans cesse parce que le régime n'arrive
pas à prouver pourquoi il fait tout ça
elle est l'intérêt réel
ça repose sur trois quatre formules et
ses trois quatre formules sont battus en
brèche par tout le monde c'est plus un
régime universel tout le monde pas
gagnant non les femmes n'y trouveront
pas leur compte donc à la femme une
masse croissante de gens se disent mais
pourquoi tu du bazar pourquoi tout
bloquer est ce qui vaudrait pas mieux
retirer discuter parce qu'à matière à
discuter
les français refusent majoritairement
très largement là
la réforme des manuels macron parce que
elle est injuste elle veut les faire
travailler plus longtemps pour gagner
moins
au moment de leur retraite alors
qu'aujourd'hui avec le régime de
retraite actuel nous pourrions financer
la retraite à 60 ans avec 40 annuités de
cotisation tout simplement avec une
mesure simple
si on paye les femmes au même salaire
que les hommes à salaire à travail
équivalent le sur la surcotisation cela
entraînerait permettrait de financer la
retraite à 60 ans et avec 40 annuités
donc aujourd'hui la volonté du
gouvernement
ce n'est pas de stabiliser le système de
retraite et le garantir c'est bien le
détruire pour le donner aux privés et
aux grands fonds d'investissements parce
qu'il existe des solutions très simples
pour financer le système actuel à l'
équilibre donc bastien lachaud député la
france insoumise expliquer son projet de
contre-réforme son contre-projet avec
les forces de gauche analyse élabore un
projet pour rencontrer celui qui
proposait par le gouvernement ici en
tout cas la situation est calme dans une
mobilisation très suivie évidemment
certaines grèves à certains endroits
certains corps de métier ses soutes mais
d'autres mobilisations au pris le dessus
comme par exemple et bien le dépôt des
outils de travail il y à des assemblées
générales il ya même un marathon dans le
pays basque pour protester contre ce
projet de réforme
et puis de nombreuses corporations aussi
rejoint le mouvement penser les avocats
les pompiers donc ici de nombreux corps
de métiers sont présents pour manifester
il n'y a pas que les syndicats
en tout cas nous suivons la situation